we all understand betrayal some of us it  was a system maybe it was our families  could have been a stranger  nothing i love more than watching grown  men squeal  [Music]  we are men we founded this country on  our backs now they want us to give up  power willingly into the hands of people  who are incapable of wielding it  over my dead  body  [Applause]  [Music]  what are we doing kind of like a pain at  the streets program  [Music]  look i don't smack you in the mouth like  to see you trying  there's some feminists who want to  attack my event  i need additional protection  [Music]  she's gonna be in a body bag before  sundown  no one's gonna give it to us so we have  to take it  you know her but you clearly don't know  me  the violence you know it's gonna come  back to you it always does  you guys are professional murderers  you're coming for your blood remember  boys be  [Music]  to  nice  you